thank you to Rocket money for sponsoring
this video more on them after the
reaction well how's it going there citizens
of the reject Nation we are here and it is
time for another solo Motion Picture reaction I
I don't know what this this thing is right here
I was trying to do a gym carry impression but
you know it's been a minute since I've watched
some Peak JY and that's what we're here
to rectify today we're watching The Mask
my friends and I know what you're thinking John
how have you not seen the mask great question I
remember kids loving this movie growing up it's
been built up very much over time we weren't a
Jim Carrey house Growing Up So suffice it
to say I got some gaps to fill in and you
guys are here to help me out with that leave a
like for going back in time for Nostalgia for
big faces and uh also don't forget to subscribe
hit that notification Bell thank thank you very
much to prepper for helping to edit down these
highlights it is a tough task and we appreciate
them for it also if you want to get the full
mask experience alongside me come on over to
patreon.com theal rejects where you can sync
up with your own copy put it in the DVD or
the Blu-ray and watch along with me we also
got a whole bunch of other stuff over there
with reaction highlights and watch alongs
included it's a blast my friends and hey
with without further Ado let's un mask this
uh the the movie roll roll the bumper we're
done this a Dark Horse comic I knew
this was like a yeah like a based on
a comic book but I didn't realize it would be dark
horse so they also do spawn who does spawn
speaking of what's the best Darkhorse comic
leave one of your favorites in the comments
maybe I'll check one out hang on a sec
oh it's been buried in the deepest
darkest depths to protect all of man
from its treacherous magic or
whatever Treasures lie [Music]
within I love they're just
opening it right here oh
what a happen dance it's also it's nice it looks
like one of those little treasure chests you get
for like a fish tank hey title cards too man back
in the day I feel like title cards had a certain
like tangibility it's different now oh Luna Tunes
I got those concert tickets you wanted you're
kidding for Friday night Stanley this is great
Stanley Stanley so what time should I pick you
up my very best girlfriend just came into town
and I know she would die to go to this could we
maybe get an extra ticket for her uhoh they're
sold out that means there's no more StubHub man
get that markup well I just can't let her sit
home all alone why don't you just go with your
friend a Stanley you are the nicest guy really
you are yeah yeah I might have done that tonight
I'm going to take you on a Love Safari what deep
into the darkest heart of the urban jungle does
that mean oh no coco bungo Club hottest new
joint in town Coco bungo Club only the creme
de La Creme need apply this is going to be the
perfect night on the town yes my man's got the
cream thunder clap excellent this already
feel feels like a like a comic book like
a Kookie comic book Selena Kyle with the
stretch Zoom nice yep oh what this camera
Diaz say then crushing right back in stand
back and observe damn where was this in her
R wow nice smokey eye dude uh where was this
in her rise to stardom you know you're lucky
you caught me I was just on my way out to
a very you hold this for me please I will
hold anything you want is this a fantasy can
you help me [Music] what okay I guess this is
real the drawer is a metaphor what kind of account
do you have in mind I'm not sure exactly you see
I'm just terrible with things like that this
is me at the bank that's an interesting time
Mr IUS Stanley ipus iiss kind of reminds me
of one of those what do you call it ink blot
tests War Shack test right may I may what such
a mess oh my oh of course that's what they're
there for yep just that you know it sort
of looks like um yes bear your psychology
a young woman riding bear back sort of a lady a
diver or something what do you see Mr this is a
fantasy just just a tip there it's a power
to It's supposed to make you feel powerful
oh does it work Mr Gray will see you ow
that was a little bit of uh what's that
movie where Sharon Stone crosses her legs
that one it's the only thing I know about
that different [Music] plans just get
your bingo card out for for phallic and
otherwise Randy metaphor in uendi yes okay
I was like there's no way that this is just
genuine she's really good at that though like I
can see why people fell in love with camera Diaz
immediately what do you think it's not bad them
uh motion detectors are a pain in the yes sure oh
my God it's it's um what's his name you talking
to the doctor I do have one question you're the
doctor tyy wiy what does nioep say about all this
nothing seen his gri man get real man everything
is his grift he owns you he owns this club he
owns this old stinking Town yeah get real you
mess with Nico you end up taking a dirt nap hey
sleeping with the fishes he's the only one who's
napping oh that's that's good and I'm about to
give him a serious wake up call and I'm going
to wear this around town so first we take the
bank then we take n and then my friend school is
out
fascinating I would love if that scene just
went on for another minute while they both
just laugh back and forth at each other I'm
here for the Civic breaks are shot and you
need a new transmission is your name Ernie
hey B all I wanted was an oil chain change
oh well you lucky You' CAU these problems
now before they cause you some serious
trouble in like 15 years I have to have a
car tonight bring around The Loner oh my
God hey you clay bar that put some fresh paint
on it that's a cool ass ride all right and fix
all the guts you get what I mean gals want
you meet my buddy Stanley IUS humongo in the
banking business oh he's just there he's not
the door man yo Bobby how you doing buddy ug
Charlie how you how are you how you doing
how's it going see you okay then whoa damn
dog see on the inside Charlie got the hook up
a Bobby uh Charlie Charlie wow Charlie is a
terrible sidick that's what you call wingman in a
comic book never cross the Rope no but my friends
are on the inside hey come on lose them ouchies
you put me down right to help I am never coming
back here ow oh jeez yeah man your whole drip
is [Applause] dripping damn dude you're going
to have to jump that guy now oh oh oh oh no are
you okay I'm great really good I just your car
sir not my car oh boy the ticket it you are
Employee of the Month there sir but I am very
angry Jim Carrey is really good at doing you know
like you driving in a Porche he's good at doing
obviously the the broad slapstick but still you
know tempering it with discernable emotionality
like like when he's sad or hurt it it still comes
through I'm beginning with these viewings to
basically appreciate the dimensionality
of him as a performer Beyond just the
obvious thing's about to fall
apart woo I felt that [Laughter]
yeah oh my god oh how many takes was
that that was beautiful oh my God they
must have been timing and pulling all
the pieces like specifically oh the
world's better off with you George Bailey
don't jump whoa oh the diver hey Clarence
and he works the savings and loow is this
going to be a secret It's a Wonderful Life
H trash man it's swap thing oh oh it's
got like a mask of its [Music] own
ah that makes more sense I was like is he just
going to put it on but it has an Allure you
have any idea what time it is actually no
OU my new carpet well this is coming right
out of your security deposit ipus yep my rent
hard did you do back at the laboratory to get
your bullets tightened o I should have
said that it's okay it's all right was
that a Frankenstein joke or a Franken hooker
joke hey the wolf the cartoon wolf I like how
many like you know Looney tuny kind of things
they're peppering in here too just is you know
iconography a I'll throw it one
time I going to throw it with you
attached to it whoa oh that that's going to happen
later all right Mrs peenman Mrs peenman
oh that's a character name for you so Dr
Newman you're saying that everybody wears a
mask that's correct he V Stein we suppress
the ID our darkest desires and adopt a more
socially acceptable image that's you man is
of course the masks we wear by the dog
does trust thank you so much for being
with us today some good cover art what
are you looking for huh yeah the dog
knows you like it don't throw it to him that's
correct Wendy we all wear masks metaphorically
speaking oh Mirror Mirror on the wall yeah
right yeah right interesting line response to
that oh don't fall prey to its [Music] glamour
whoa yep it's fun how much they've teased this
oh oh my w shees says Taz with the Taz
pillow is there this much Ludy Tunes in
the comic oh smoken smoken it's party
time p a r t why because I gotta yes
yes yes yes you do oh my God that suit
the suspenders the [Music] tie oh she
just wanted quiet before I thought she was
just policing what he watches not that it's
loud oh you're like Roger Rabbit
Man okay so
like
oh
excellent W
damn this is
[Music] fascinating this is a fascinating blend of
things oh hey get in the back he wants
to communicate this guy's breaking the
[Music] fourth this is so wild it's like
Deadpool before Deadpool or or maybe not
but I you know depending on the where's Coy
when did they start writing Deadpool comics
1991 February 1991 was the issue but the book
was actually released December 11th 1990 cuz
technically Comics come out earlier than the
publication date 1991 is the Jeopardy answer
1990 if you lived it got the time as a matter
of fact I do Cubby Cubby it's exactly 2 seconds
before I honk your nose and pull your underwear
over your head oh [Music] no oh from the front ah
I mean it's terrible either way but hey little
anal dwelling butt monkey damn nobody likes a
bhead go with the Mo having a great
time I'd like to do something for you
son we have a giraffe yes we do
there you go son get out of here
you bother me you bother me last but not least my
favorite do that magic trick where you eat
it hey W tummy [Music] gun is he
actually shooting him or trying
to what are the physics what are the rules
with these Powers I could be oh oh oh a
super hero I could fight crime protect
the innocent Qui for World Peace but
first truth justice in the American way who
oh first hold on to your great great use of
props that is very
cartoon did a dream yes yes of course so I'm
protect the innocent fight crime and all that
stuff but first i'm going be the [__] out of
these guys who are scamming me on my auto repair
ipus Stanley ipus wait a minute that's Lieutenant
kellway City Precinct you know anything about the
disturbance last night what's that guy's name
some kind of Prowler broke in and attacked Mrs
peenman oh no you didn't hear anything oh it
wasn't a dream a 20 or buck shot 5 ft from
your door at the FL see that he put that right
in my floor then he jumped out the window this
is impossible those pajamas are impossible
hey hey the tie is impossible all right if
you remember anything unusual about last
night call me thank you and uh good luck
crack in the case yep oh my God I'm late oh
it's 7:43 keys keys where's the keys oh this
is me leaving for every shoot mil get the keys
get him find him you got this Milo we believe
in you get the keys so he's like like a Looney
Tunes superhero essentially is that like that's
cool I always I always knew this would be like
a wacky movie you know like a comedy obviously
Jim Carry but yeah like the idea that it's an
actual like slapstick cartoon version of the
superhero and great color contrast with the
pillow there yep complimentary [Music] colors
whoa careful careful Milo doesn't run after that
and jump out the window [Music] jeez what is it
like drawn to him did it like choose him cuz
it knows he loves Looney Proctologist standing
by who you heard me best one you can find oh my
God sorry the Proctologist line took me a second
there it is boys she broke the case come on get
out of here up Paul Riser is it no he's got a
slightly different face where were you last night
the girls and I were looking all over for you did
you happen to look outside in the gutter yeah
this is all your fault dude you're a horrible
wingman 40 minutes late now that's the same as
stealing ner a more American word hath
been spoken oogling girly pictures you
might actually get some work done around here
she's a prospective client of Stanley's oh
really American sentiment I should say the
next time she comes in you be sure to send
her to my office of course you bet you so she's a
singer performer and she's on a crew for a Griff
crime Heist Stanley listen to me a girl like
that is always looking for the BBD a better
deal feeling the blank she's sensitive Stanley
forget her that girl will tear out your heart
put it in a blender and hit tra head ooh extra
shot you need somebody a little more down to
earth somebody with some Integrity somebody with
red hair oh and full pouting lips what a green
jacket and a name tag dude you're the cartoon
wolf man may I be of some assistance Stanley
ypus I'm Peggy Brandt from the Tribune look
I canceled my subscription because they kept
stealing my paper from oh no actually I just
want to ask you a few questions about what
Ripley Auto finishing you're a customer of
theirs aren't you wow thorough me no I don't
even have a car you don't own an 89 Civic wow
you just got their whole like receipt file and
everything It's All Coming Back to Me Jesus
what did you say your name was Peggy Brandt
Peggy Brandt you printed one of my letters
last year nice guys finish last nice gu yes
wow do you realize how much mail we got about
that letter I mean there are literally hundreds
of women out there looking for a guy just
like you oh no a a nice guy TM you know how
hard it is to find a decent man in this town
most of them think monogamy is some kind of
wood you know it's only an H away why are you
covering this story because dear Peggy pays dick
I'm starving to death I'm looking to become
a real reporter so many loaded lines I just
want the truth God I wish I knew the truth you
know me too you really think hundreds of women
looking for a guy like me sure can I meet all
100 of them I'm one of them wow oh oh my dude
what a the the me cute on that jeez next time
why don't you call right leave the delivery
boys at home oh Jesus this guy reminds me of
Chris sanon but it's not Chris sandon whoa
what do we got oh Jeeps you will be the tea
the cops uh tried to shut the club down this
morning oo they say you've been using the place
to run your own Small Time scams I hear things
like that I start losing my concentration
oh yeah it goes straight to hell oh you good
too yep out one week to get out of
town I'll usually r l go to Breaking
my new nine iron yeah this is the most
Sinister Golf Scene in cinema history
damn oh the siren Call
summons a s song for the
alliteration please be like The Dumb and Dumber
dream he's so good at that at at
blending the swaave the timing but the
wacky so much
[Applause] [Music] punctuation oh my yep oh yep
Milo stop it stop it Tina come on we can my n your
buddy bombshell explodes I always wonder
where we got that term for beautiful blonde
[Laughter] people the solution to my confidence
and assertiveness issue is simply that I need
to become this wacky man with a green
[Music] face oh did it pull you that
time hold on Sugar Daddy's got a sweet too
tonight oh yes careful you don't catch a
cavity oh damn that was good that's good great
minds hey whoa Sweeney te careful somebody stop
hey damn can't make the scene if you don't have
the green I better make a little St kids used to
say that all the time smoking and somebody
stopped me how's it going F looking good
here my man my man I got to get downstairs and
make sure I've seen a I saw that the doctor is
about to operate I would love it if this guy
is just Doctor Who on on like a sidebar his
outfits like he could be and his Vibe if he was
a little more Whimsical I'm sad he works [Music]
for sorry fellas why
not so he just rob the bank or is he just taking
the money for safekeeping that's not that guy with
the long hair look familiar too it's not Chris
hod doll is it this is the official movie of
that gu whose name I can't [Music] pull oh that
not Tom Cruz guy looked a little familiar too
not Tom cruz/ notot Dennis Quaid oo uh are you on
the list but I believe my friends are perhaps you
know them Grant and Jackson my friends George
Washington George Washington George Washington
George Washington Etc hey the door man is
is is not Kevin Pollock is it I don't think
so it looks kind of like him most beautiful
flower of the Coco Bango Miss Tina car let's
go Jessica [Music] Rabbit o is she
[Music]
singing It's like just like a rabbit but
also like where is this in relation to
cool world isn't there like a blonde
torch singer lady in cool [Music]
world great example of makeup working with
an actor w and probably very handy that it's
green given the CGI embellishments they
undoubtedly have to do we got trouble he
better come upstairs that's not Cru at all
kind of looks like Brad derf but also not
him yep and it's like when the
CG could be better like it's fine
because it's supposed to be cartoony
although part of me wonders what it
would look like if they did some
actual like Roger Rabbit handdrawn
style for a moment like this
for example but but also I
mean that looked great like that
was really funny let's rock this
joint
whoa oh [Music] yeah baby this is
like an Ultimate Fantasy if you
could bust up into some joint and
be like change the music and now
I'm going to stop the show with my
dance moves like [Music] heyy yeah
oh and very easy to swap out with a stunt
man for him if you need to or a stunt
dancer someone hit the joint before we cut
uh-oh suck suck on it no that guy this man
my oh that guy that's the guy that guy dancing
with he's dead deed me James whoa good framing
yeah like there's a lot of stuff that needs to be
on point for a movie like this to [Music] work hey
[Music] wow oh my wow knock the socks off what
a cun no his his PJs you think I'm joking come
on move I like that this guy has risen you know
to such a status as a Hench but with you know
those luscious locks I want to know what my money
is and I want to know right now okay oh [Music]
you've got 17.5% in tea bills amortized over
the fiscal year fortunately funeral bouquet are
deductible hey yes it's a business expense oh
who are you trying to tell me that I can dodge
splits hey you got to get that Russian dance
in there got to get an Elvis in [Music] there
how many bullets all right got me partner I
did it only took me like eight shots to get
there yes go bugs me close
red H any am the little yell her out
teeth Telly Tim I would be coming
home this Christmas yes yet every
death tell Scarlet I do give [Music]
Dam thank you this is great you really love
me this is like the perfect movie for Jim
Carrey back to the show hey Callaway so
you got a warrant this time or you just
stop by for a night Gap oh what I got
is probable cause couple of your boys
were spotted knocking over red
City Bank easy Juni give me a
wood I am erected why aren't you arre we got a
stiff upstairs it's one the guys from the heights
call that high price lawyer of yours Terrell
you and I are going downtown for a little chat
he that other cop who just came in looks like he
could be like a Jim Carrey double oh no of course
both explains part of the physics of his costume
change kiss but it also provides yes good dramatic
piece of obstacle uh embellishment oh my God you
got to get that thing a body pillow dude who yep
yep yep yep does the mask not work during the
daytime open up I'm getting my oh my God and the
Frisbee wow listen this isn't the uh best time
right now I just oh where were you last night IUS
here what do you know about this mask character
mask he robs the bank you work in and then I
find this in the cocoa Bongo there can't be two
idiots with pajamas like these that looks like
was something someone wear to the cocoa Bongo
may I see those pajamas Mr ripus those uh those
pajamas were stolen somebody stole your [Music]
pajamas I mean dude what is uh what is this City
coming to just hanging off the door knob handle
whatever P drawer is no longer safe oh he does
have a little birdie look at that guy nobody's
at fast at my bank I'll [Music] say they're just
treating it like he's abnormally fast the bank
employee files and run on the prints on a guy
named ipus Stanley ipus you figure was an inside
job huh that's right and all I need is a couple of
Prince to lock this whack job up till doomsday
and some more of America's favorite fr R thank
you to McDonald's for sponsoring this scene I want
you to get the word out I want him here tomorrow
alive how about tonight you're losing it Dorian
I'm not losing anything except maybe some extra
baggage around here yeah you weren't putting up
much of a fight with that freak Show last night
when he tried to kiss you did it look like I had
much of a choice yeah he seduced me with cartoon
physics I'll tell you one thing it's going to be
payback for anybody who crosses me this movie also
has the right amount of seriousness when it needs
to like the the crime scenes have to be committed
enough have a crisis on our hands here and you
stroll in over an hour late if I have to put
up with your sloly behavior back off monkey boy
Whoa monkey bone before I tell your daddy you're
running this place like it's your own personal
piggy bank or maybe we should call the IRS and
see if we can arrange a little vacation for you
at Club ooh here's the thing monkey boy that'll
be all ifus damn dog you just fight clubbed your
manager that was genius buddy what side of Whose
Bed did you wake up on man The Mask side of my own
two tickets to the charity ball at the Coco Bango
Club this Saturday night want to be my date oh
you're you shouldn't have I just wanted to thank
you but I'm not sure if I'm going to have much to
open account with anymore what about the club I
thought you were doing great oh no crime sales
are down you didn't stop by just to see me did
you it's okay tell me God that that suit she's
got the guy they say Rob this ni I think he was
at the club last night really I think that's
a solid guess a solid conjecture you ought to
see him dance she's not about the looks why are
you interested just curious I guess you'd like
to see him again wouldn't you this is a very
Peter Parker kind of moment I um wouldn't mind
I know him you know I'm his photographer we're
old college buddies him and me it's funny you
should mention the way dances because oh no
I taught him a couple of dance moves myself
ohuh do you think you can have him meet me
tonight I might be able to work something out
oh Landfield Park okay Sunset perfect super
hey Jesus looks like fourth or fifth century
Scandinavian possibly a representation of one
of the Norse Knight Gods maybe Loki ly the god
of Marvel who's who's ly god of we need to get
you a Disney Plus account Odin banished him from
Valhalla forever then he could have banished
him into that mask why not this is a piece of
wood but it's green my book is about masks as
a metaphor Mr epas not to be taken literally
you're suffering from a mild delusion uh-oh I'm
going to prove it to you uh yeah he crosses his
eyes
sing Michigan jrog sing
[Music] dance you got to get that Jim Carrey
hip thrust you said Loki was a night God maybe
it only works at night it there we go if you would
like me to arrange for a safe environment for you
tonight I can do that no no I have a tate I've
got a C Tina do I go as myself or the mask if I
tell you you promise to leave my office right now
[Laughter] go as yourself and as the mask yes are
both one and the same beautiful person hey oh he
empowered him just as much as he was like [Music]
sched oh hey hey he's got a document Stanley what
are you doing here I I just wanted to come by and
and make sure that you two got together all
right oh you know I I hardly ever stopped by
here it's kind of hard to believe it was just a
garbage heap wow uh it's really beautiful right
around Sunset look at that Borealis city of
methane Sky pollution just for you my friend
will be along here any minute I I I better
go oh are you sure Stanley oh hello yeah is
it written in the stars that we are destined
to frat eyes oh kiss me my dear and I will
[Music] reveal yeah dude I love it no dude
you're peepy law now you can't just be the
ID you can't just be the Mask wait I need
backup and I need it [Music] now I wish I
could blow a smoke ring or heart black Napoleon
I will conquer I don't know dude askar Le got
about that police mailed mailed you knew it
was coming is that the most popular swear
word in a non-english language you're under
arrest it wasn't me it was the one armed man
yes Richard Kimbell fugitive let's do this
what are they going to do to me S what are
they going to do Ser ow no you got to do one
of those where's a camcorder when you need
one that line is aged up oh my goodness never
seen those before in life I have a permit for that
concealed carry what what maret ug son of a [__]
jeez I figured you had a sense of humor after all
you married her did she get like got to hurt
yep did she get like a professional bed [Music]
shot this is like a monster movie where it's
like you know the the blend of practical
effects of CGI like all enhance the thing like
this is like the comedy version of that where
it's like you have the right performer the
right makeup and then CGI to embellish the
already huge performance open fire oh what
do you got it oh yeah let's go hey nice cut
back costume change CH [Music] Maracas
oh my god dude Chim Cary must do so much
yoga
used to fair amount right there's got to be some
notable chick chicky boom set
pieces in [Music] movies [Music]
oh [Music] yes even though this is one
big distraction it's stop B you know it's
just causing unity and joy oh who's that
flying by like trape artists there he is
let's get him snap out of it yeah were
you firing at one of the people in the
sky no oh
oh oh
oh look like Nick Cage for a second there stany
get in there he is damn she going to risk her
life for you shoot stop her my mom shoot shoot wow
everybody shoot that car I saw it what's happening
to you Stanley dang I'm losing control when I put
that mask on I can do anything be anything yeah
uh you got to combine it with your core self or
the other parts of yourself I don't know what's
happening to you Stanley but I do know this that
letter that you sent my column that was from a guy
with more guts and more heart a whatever that
mask is you don't need it yeah you are already
all you'll ever need to be a do you really mean
that actually no yeah what took you guys so long
I've been here for like 20 minutes what she's in
with them give her the money I guess that tracks
both these women who are very drawn to him kind
of inexplicably sorry Stanley but you really are
a great guy I just can't lose my condo you know
how hard it is to find an apartment in this city
is her name piggy Brandt is there Betty Brandt in
something you said you wouldn't hurt him hi I lied
how's this mask work I don't know you just put it
on is it there a movie where that actually happens
and there's like a big red smear on the paper
it's like an actual gruesome [Music] scene oh
no whoa but you're not the chosen one man
you don't you better be careful huh you
don't love Looney Tunes the way this guy
loves Looney Tunes you can't handle the
slapstick
oh gigachad mask what do we do with ipus
the police are looking for the mask so
we'll give them the mask damn though you're
like the Monster version money better be here
iiss or you can IP kiss your ass goodbye
he spent a long time coming up with that
one
Orlando dudes used to rock the only ponytail
more back in the day I feel
like oh come on Milo you got
this Milo is intact live
your best life [Music] boy
oh come on Milo I still can't believe
it Harden cops dancing in the street
and broadcast all over the 11:00 News
the SWAT team got an offer to open in
Vegas oh I want to see that show a come
on Lieutenant it's not all your fault
something will turn up sure Stanley
ipus is going to fall right into my
lap oh yeah yep yep yep explain everything
explain this that's a different mask
that's that's just a prosthetic that they
probably used from one of the earlier later
scenes it's okay James James Kare Milo oh buddy
forget about me buddy find yourself a new place
to live looks like I'm going to be in here
for a long long time no hey you with the face
you Jim Carrey is maybe the one guy that that
you would actually be able to identify with that
descriptor hello Stanley what are you doing here
is it true yeah your boyfriend might be a little
upset he's going to the charity ball tonight he's
going to do something terrible oh how does it work
it's like it it it brings your innermost desires
to life if deep down inside you're a little
repressed and a hopeless romantic yeah you become
some sort of a love crazy wild man is Me Myself
and Irene kind of like that too and we're all
in big trouble and if I were you I'd get out of
town the ID versus the higher self kind of split
thanks a a sunset with me for being the only guy
who treated me like a person and not some sort of
party favor damn you know that night at the club
I knew I'd found someone special The Mask oh what
the guy inside the mask was you all along was you
Spider Man I've got to disappear for a while now
stanle I don't know where I'm going to go I'll let
you know as soon as I can oh buddy you got to go
take down Venom man you got to go beat down Eddie
Brock I like that the The Mask sorry
Edge City made me think of edge
Lord and then I was like the mask's
crazy grin almost looks like cringe
face oh no no damn not
bad something about that moment reminded me of
like LA Confidential for some reason oh my no
this is a great w cell window G there's a woman
being a chased through the alleyway there come
on she needs help yeah yeah sure keep it down
ipus there's another that guy Milo remember how
I taught you not to jump up on people forget all
that all your jumping desires will be met today
wow damn you can do it come on what are they do
is is that the dog jumping or is someone like
throwing him up there oh w [Music] yeah when it
needs to it feels like some kind of actual crime
movie I was beginning to get all worried about
you nice little talk with the cops I just went
to see what ipus told them oh that's right you
and Stanley right maybe it was you who helped
them out with the back job huh that's ridiculous
always he's got the left side earring what was
the politics of the time everyone's got a left
side earring you plan a little trip without me
baby no o if we're going to go to a party tonight
we're going to have one hell of a time aren't we
get in this D I like too the the doveet tailing
of what is it Peggy being sweet coming from like
a a reputable like oh she's a reporter and then
turning out to be the double cross and then you
have Cameron Diaz on the other side you know
part of the grift but who really just wants to
go straight and steady and leaving the operat
like that yeah I think that's nice see that
man over there he's got keys go get those keys
it's like a reverse Pirates of the Caribbean
sort of that's it yeah come on buddy come on
buddy oh did cheese budy come on dude come on
[Music] dude wow this dog is well
trained well trained animal actor
what's he watching on TV good boy give me
the keys I wonder I wonder they probably
wanted the dog to keep the key but at
the same time I'm like at what point
is he just actually saying hey come on
we got to move the scene on oh careful
Stanley oh oh he's going to close the
button oh Dam
Stan Milo no I am warning you I'm seriously
stressed out here yep you're in the middle of
a police station there is no way you're
walking out of here like this no you're
right you're absolutely right what the hell
are you doing uh you're going to take me out
as your prisoner put it on put it on wowe
that was Swift who you taking ipus he gay
and UNG oh I get it Pig Latin right e say oh my
goodness yes pig ltin is the official official
thing to use if you really want someone to
work hard and then give up on whatever you
just said I've got a change for the party yes
knock knock with the Devin mevin as I've ever
been Casino KN oh yeah [Music] like Goro and
the Hulk you driving like a maniac I'm sorry
we're already late for the ball I'm just the next
employee who's come for his back pay or should I
say pay back yes there little spawn in there kill
him oh he flinched a little bit when the guns went
off woo oh he's getting
hit I see I see come on hit
me oh
no that's that's actually kind of unsettling
ladies and gentlemen I will be your host for
the remainder of the evening so it amplifies
yeah the ID lurking within you that you need
to Wrangle and temper there is everybody someone's
not Kosher here exactly what yeah com enough the
lock in use the radio Milo this could be dangerous
you stay here and be a good boy yes the best boy
Daddy's going to have to go kick some ass how
is daddy going to have a a normal life after
this oh there's a jump cut there they
adjusted the timing on that shot blow
it oh no no this is your big production number
and you know it's important to go out with a big
bang I like that the the bad guys even put
you know cautionary signs on the box look
take this gun start sneaking people out the
back right God he looks like a James Bond
character and he looks almost like a dirty
hay dirty Cary this part is over oh in 10
minutes just enough time when a man shows what
he's really made of oh look out crap made of
crap [Music] oh where are you going hey boss
look who decided to crash the party this guy's
familiar too bring him up here wait no there's
no time for last request but all I wanted was
a kiss uhoh Dorian I can't shut this thing
off there's always time for a kiss EG from
the real Doran the one I used to love oh smart
this whole place is going to blow in a couple
couple minutes yeah just wait look at those lips
they gave him too those details I decided I have
decided hey one last through a lot of buildup for
that cut oh yeah oh yeah excellente [Music] no oh
oh oh we're doing that the Frisbee the
frisbee excellent it's all over now oh [Music]
ouch oh no
oh they're doing it they're doing it oh my
God no oh how many things is this dog going to
hump [Music]
yep no [Music] nope damn dude it's
going Ralphie Parker on him [Music]
Nice Shot nicely done with that Dolly
embellishment waa got to get him on the
butt got to do all the dog jokes oh my God this
has got to be a new breed yes the new breed the
new batch oh oh buddy okay I'm happy Milo got
to wear the mask but I'm also happy that was
shortlived excellent shooting gang
excellent work today oh did you miss
[Music] me classic stick Tracy over here now you
you have to ask yourself one question do
I feel lucky well oh do I do you was it
Bruce Almighty that made his face like
look like Clint would to do that same
line stany excellent but that is the difference
between what Stanley would do
and what the other guy would
do a [Music] wow Yep this guy is
encourageable God his jaw action hey smart smart
good thing you didn't get any
Acme products along the way oh
nice you were good kid real good long as I'm
around you'll always be second best see those
teeth [Music] man oh see you're learning to
balance you're learning to apply what the mask
can teach you but curb its basist instincts
and desires police hands up officers arrest
those men oh I've always wanted to say that
you know I'll give it to you man you are not
a good wingman at all but I'll give it to you
man is the mask no Dorian Tyrell was the mask
I saw with my own ass yes smart wow you're a real
hero ah any American with balls of steel wouldn't
do for his community yep you sure you know
what you're doing buddy I'm sure go exit The
Truman Show you sure you're not going to miss
this guy when he's gone all that's left is me
a he's looking at you kid a the kiss we did it
we got that [Applause] [Music] kiss where are
you going dude you're just going to leave oh my
God Jesus Christ no Father in Heaven please not
this guy this guy does not get the mask oh Milo
what the hell see I can yeah see see it's in you
just got to make sure to keep it proportional
and want a freeze frame to end on that was so
lovely oh my goodness oh oh my friends gonna
gonna take a minute to drink in the cast right
here but but we did it thank you to Rocket money
for sponsoring this video a brand that I am happy
to be partnered with thrilled to it's fortunately
one that I have been using for quite a while now
prior to ever agreeing to a partnership with
them I was like that makes for the best kind
of synergy promotion because I can actually talk
about them from my heart here reason being like
many of you guys uh like for years I constantly
downloading all kinds of financial apps that
I keep forgetting to use or I don't really find
quite as beneficial rocket money has been the one
the only one I'm not just saying it is the only
one that I have been able to consist recently use
ReliOn that has been an absolute game Cher for
me on a very personal note running real rejects
is an absolute privilege however you know like I
stress out about taxes and it's the beginning of
the year and I'm like I'm trying to be smarter
and get it all done now I already started like
a couple months ago getting things in order
managing real rejects finances while managing
my own personal finances has been an ongoing
struggle and I'm very big on like efficiency and
being organized but clearly wasn't as good enough
as I uh thought I had been so before rocket money
came into my life I was drowning in subscriptions
and struggling to keep track of my expenses and as
I really wanted to like get everything in order
rocket money came at the right time for me I was
overwhelmed with subscriptions I didn't even
know I had or had still been subscribed to I
mean do you ever wonder how many subscriptions you
actually pay for have you ever taken the time to
really do it it could be a little daunting rocket
money helped me see what I was missing and best
part they even cancelled those subscriptions for
me with just a simple tap so with rocket money you
can have all your subscriptions in one place
making it easy to cancel anything unnecessary
without the hassle of dealing with customer
service my is so annoying plus they'll work
on getting you refunds and negotiate lower bills
saving you up to 20% you just snap a pick of your
bill and let rocket money take care of the rest
let me just summarize for you really quick what
they are they're personal finance app that fines
and cancels unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps lower your bills with over 5
million users and over $500 million and cancel
subscriptions they've already saved members an
average of $720 a year they helped save me a
little bit more than that don't waste your hard
earn money on unused subscriptions cancel them
today at Rocket money.com rejects that's rocket
money.com rejects if you've heard other people
talk about them well use ours Rocky money.com
rejects cuz if you use that promo code rejects
you unlock special benefits and yes using them is
also a great way to support the channel same time
it's just a great way to support your bank account
cuz I cannot stress enough just how much this app
has changed the game for me take control of your
finances with rocket money and enjoy Financial
Peace of Mind oh guys hey first and foremost
before we hop into this review uh why don't
you go ahead leave five stars if I could I would
have had uh you know my hand stretch out and you
know do some kind of crazy number five thing but
yeah if you're listening on Apple and Spotify uh
leave us your thoughts and opinions but mostly
leave us that rating helps us out a lot and uh
you know what I got to say first and foremost Jim
Carrey Stanley ipus the mask in particular the
drips throughout this movie The Costume design
was lovely and terrific and I mean across the
board from again just like the The Outfits they
had Cameron Diaz in the outfits that they had the
freaking pajamas they had Jim Cary in all the
different elegant partygoers the criminals the
biker gangs so many great flourishes in terms
of uh wardrobe and Aesthetics and speaking of
wardrobe and it's just regation shop.com if you
want to support the channel and uh Rock aresh and
uh reject Nation drip uh come on over there it's
a great way to support the channel it's one of
our favorites we got new designs going up quite
frequently I made a bunch of Doctor Who jokes
during this and Doctor Who we got a do Doctor Who
Inspire t-shirt it's one of the best sellers thus
far we got space babies of the Galaxy we got Child
Protection Services the Classic ticket we got a
whole bunch of other things are probably flashing
up on screen but yeah if you want to jump on over
there and I will finish Shilling and uh move
on to talking about this movie it's so cool to
finally yeah to finally fill in again one of the
fun things about this whole experience is that you
know yes we get to talk about the current things
and break those down and kind of you know give
our thoughts and ideas about him but it's always
a blast and it feels like continuing you know Film
School in some kind of cultural way when we get
to watch one of these Classics and and yeah this
was hilarious like this this really lived up to
just the Mystique that it is crude over time at
least for you know my perception of it uh and
and you know going back to especially a comedy
you're always like how is this going to hold up
by today's standards and just by where I am as a
viewer Now versus like if I had seen this when I
was like you know between 10 and 15 or something
like that you know I might have you know really
had a blast but actually this is an example of a
movie where you know watching it now gave me
so much lovely appreciation for the context
just as much as just the the direct experience of
watching the movie because yeah I mean this was
really fun and funny and it was really fun to see
Jim Carrey in you know his Heyday uh you know and
at the height of his comedic you know presence
in Hollywood before I think this is like what
slightly before or maybe even a good stretch
before he was breaking out into more dramatic
roles and things like that um but it really just
gives you that huge appreciation like I I I feel
like Jim Carrey wasn't prominent in my house
growing up because of just like the overwhelming
stick is stick is nature of his whole you know
onscreen Persona uh and then we might not have
had an Adam Sandler for the broadness but also
the the crudeness the crassness and whatnot um
and so yeah this was fun because you know I've
been able to go back and appreciate you know
some of the stuff that I missed from the Jim
Carrey catalog up until now uh and like Dumb
and Dumber was another one of those where I'm
like this is a perfect movie for this guy and
it's funny that this should be like a comic book
thing because we've talked about you we did like
a Batman movie ranking a couple years ago and I
watched Batman Forever for that and uh and Batman
Forever is an example of one of those that you
know Jim Carrey is in that that represents sort
of what I uh was maybe repelled by or didn't love
back in the day which is that you know I know a
lot of people love his ridd I know this is kind
of a hot take but yeah I found it mostly just
kind of loud and obnoxious and it didn't really
click in for me whereas this is an example of a
character uh like with a comedian like this I I
guess for my taste I like to see something that
requires them to fully play a character along with
bringing their natural uh you know n their stick
whatever it is there's a reason and I know again
a lot of people don't love this movie problematic
or whatever like an Adam Sandler movie that I love
that I gravitate towards Like You Don't Mess with
the Zohan because he's a full-on character there
and here I feel like this is a great balance of
Jim Carrey being you know the Everyman kind ofish
guy plus wackiness that you require from you know
the the more traditional comedic and romantic
things that this movie is going for but yeah
you need somebody who can embody this Looney
Tune character and I don't know much about the
mask as a comic or as a strip or anything like
that but from what this is telling me you know
it's basically a superhero that you know has
those kinds of powers and Aesthetics it's all
slapstick it's all comedic it's all very animated
and very steeped in the tradition of animation
and for me as a viewer that converges on a whole
bunch of things that I love and I thought yeah
Jim Carrey was absolutely perfectly suited for
because again he's got the crazy physicality and
the rubber face and all that stuff but I think
that one thing that I wouldn't have picked up
if I had seen this and and really been able to
perceive it back in the day is how that stuff is
great and funny and and you know well timed and
all that stuff like the comedy is really on but
you have to be able to temper that with uh you
know the right emotionality when a scene needs
to be a little more straight or a little more
heartfelt or whatever it might be and like this
is an example of a movie where I think he's really
good at that and there are other movies you know
in his film that I have seen that you know adjust
the levels on that and maybe play a little more
Earnest than something like this does um but I was
just so dazzled by and swept up by this because
yeah the whole movie F uh felt like it embodied
that sensibility you know it had enough uh you
know straight shooting a little shooting sound of
the other credits there to punctuate that perfect
uh you know it knew when to take like the crime
scenes seriously uh at least enough and I'm going
to pull up the IMDb because again this is this is
like a movie full of that guys um but yeah like
this movie knew when to play seriously enough and
I thought all the actors they got even in smaller
roles like some of the henches there are these
character actors or on the police force like they
all fill out the cast really well and again they
can all contend with and compete with Jim Carrey
and compliment Jim Carrey and provide the proper
foils Peter ryer okay he was the cop Peter Green
was Dorian I feel like these are you know uh uh
faces I would have been yeah Richard Jenny used
to seeing maybe more uh you know just back in the
day or in these yeah older uh in an older era of
movies um okay this guy's Z in Pulp Fiction and
things like that like yeah it's it's like I I like
that he got to Dawn the mask and and get a little
wacky as well um but that yeah yeah you have this
movie that knows appropriately when to play Broad
and early on when to kind of throw you into the
quirkiness kind of making you wonder like is this
a fantasy is this a dream no I guess okay so it
establishes the height of its World already and
then adds The Mask into that you need the right
amount of tempering to make a movie like this work
and I think that also ties into the message of
the movie which is you know it's another one of
those classic stories where it's about yeah you
get this McGuffin that brings out a certain aspect
of your character uh that you initially think just
doesn't exist within you at all it allows you
to become a whole new kind of person that has
these qualities that maybe you have wished you
could possess and then slowly learning no these
do exist inside you you just have repressed them
and some of them yeah are are urges you need to
curb and or quash and you know maybe yeah build
out of your approach to living um but some of the
these things you do do need a little bit more
of you know you could stand to be a little bit
more forward or expressive or whatever it might
be and I'm wondering now if uh if Me Myself and
Irene doesn't have a similar kind of quality but
maybe you're like splitting those aspects up into
two different people or something either way you
know like there's enough going on that this felt
like super appropriate to what it is or at least
again the the prospect of a comic strip with this
conceit adapted into a motion picture and yeah I
really like the effects um you know it is CG you
know I think a Roger Rabbit would be certainly a
comparison Point here and that dazzles with its
blend of 2D with yeah 2D classic animation drawn
animation with liveaction stuff um but yeah this
had you know more of a CGI approach to that which
you know at the time I imagine this was probably
pushing the boundaries of what CG can do which
is cool to see and it's one of those things where
yeah even if it doesn't look photo real that's
okay and that probably helps you know like the
cartoonishness probably helps just as a nerd I
would have loved to have seen a couple gags that
were in the handdrawn tradition but uh again you
know the blending it's like I said during the the
reaction it's like a lot of especially apparent in
Monster movies and things like that is is you know
the combination of physical and visual and makeup
effects you know to sell monsters or or action
and this movie kind of helped me to to further
clarify the idea that slapstick is like the action
iteration of Comedy you know it's it's it's that
thing that involves stun and specific timing and
all those things and so yeah this is kind of
like a monster movie in a way but with comedy
instead so you have this prosthetic makeup that
you know helps to enhance the natural uh zaniness
of Jim Carrey's expressions and whatnot and then
you have the you know just way in which he is so
beautifully able to you know beyond that yeah you
know create these punctuated uh you know emotions
and expressions and things and then you know you
can take that you know further into fantasy with
the use of CG and other things and yeah this was
a movie that required a combination of effects and
stuff and and funny you know yeah the mask should
be green so I can only imagine that that probably
just helped the effects as much as it did just
you know stay true to what I imagin the original
design would have been um and yeah like there's a
lot of other comic book movie aspects to this as
well that aren't doing it the way it not as much
doing it like you would see them today where it's
like hey we're paying homage it's like no like
their aspects of this like especially when um
the villain gets the mask uh and he's you know
basically turning into like the Venom version
It's like a kind of like a dark Spider-Man Peter
Parker thing and you know Tina comes to see him
and she's got this whole thing where she is drawn
to Stanley but she's also drawn to the mask But
ultimately it's really the qualities of Stanley
that she's actually you know responding to um and
you know certainly other flourishes and certain
tonal things felt like maybe it could have been
hearkening to spawn which I haven't seen as a
movie but I'm familiar with at least some of
the iconography of and it also has that you know
bit with Loki where they you know acknowledge the
the myth you know obviously Marvel and create that
although that's a fun thing reminiscent of other
mythology and Comics it does enough just enough
with that benstein character to address that idea
of the theme of The Masks we put on the people we
aspire to be and I love that that moment plays out
with him basically just actually encouraging him
despite the obvious awkwardness of the situation
and the fact that he thinks he's bit deranged he's
still like go as both people be yourself but also
brings out some of those more assertive qualities
that you think you could benefit from and realize
that they're both just you and even though yes
I mean there is a McGuffin there is some sci-fi
thing happening here with an actual magic mask
you know it's like you didn't have to do that
and I feel like a lot of movies nowadays wouldn't
weave a theme that way the way that this movie
did you know and yeah you know like classic film
Noir things or things like Dick Tracy uh which
is another thing I should see at some point but
yeah there were certainly like film Noir crime
classic tropes here you've got the you know the
uh what do they call it the Coco uh Coco Bongo
the you know Copa Cabana style like you know big
band club and you know your fem fatals and you've
got your you know journalist who turns out to be
like a double cross and you know the food chain of
crime and the cops and everything and yeah this
just managed to blend so many things together
it's a fun mad cap way and to have you know like
again a story that matches your requisite comedy
for this time period especially where it's just
like yeah a you know nice guy who's a little bit
timid and maybe a bit down on his luck trying to
you know uh improve his life and and you know get
the good gig and get the girl and all that other
you know basic stuff and uh and yeah it's got that
uh and it's got you know a bit of a romance but
then yeah it's got this whole superhero Thing
and multiple identities thing without having to
get too overwrought with any of those qualities
and in a way that yeah lets the imagination and
the fun and the wildness shine and you get some
of the you know awkward comedy of you know like
discovery of of how this thing works and how it
you know uh interacts with regular people and
how to you know stifle the the aftermath it's
like when he's trying to clean up the apartment
when the cops at his door uh you know and sort of
learning to harness this force that has you know
come into your life and even just the Simplicity
of the opening of you know You' got this diver and
there's almost like a peripheral magic where this
diver goes down opens the chest The Mask floats
out you get the sense that it's something that
was put there you know long ago for you know a
reason washed away by time and then you know the
pipe immediately Falls and knocks the dude out
and then you know even the way he finds it and
then even those moments that like it I like when
movies and I feel like this used to happen more in
the past when they'll remind you of things and Nod
to stuff but again it's more it's it's not really
taking any kind of break not that movies directly
say that but I think there is more of like you'll
see movies now with a greater sensibility of like
oh let's leave an Applause break here you know
like they're they're not doing that so it's kind
of up to you to just catch these things and and
appreciate them or not um but yeah like I thought
it was rich with those things and I really like
the chemistry of Cameron Diaz and I bought uh
Amy yasbeck uh you know the Peggy Brandt like
you know even though again this isn't the kind of
movie where we can spend the utmost amount of time
with those characters the classic tropes help you
to identify with who they are and then you know
you like uh Peggy enough and she's Charming enough
that when that double cross happens it is a major
surprise and you are bummed because at least
for me early on I was like man they both seem
like kind of kind of great like I could see how
he would be great with either of them in in one
way or another um and so yeah this is an example
of a movie that you know it feels more classic
because yeah it's doing all the craziness that
you would expect and it certainly is a vehicle
for presence like Jim Carrey um but it seems like
a lot of care went into how to shoot this and how
to you know bring energy to everything that was
going on cuz sometimes comedies can be shot flat
even effects comedies can be shot kind of flat
aside from their you know set pieces whereas this
yeah I just felt like one of those older movies
where like every little thing had a joke on it
everything had color even the incidental things
had some type of Personality there are a lot of
great character actors across the board and uh and
yeah man like this is great I had such a I so I I
as much as you know again people going to be like
how' you never like you know being aware of it for
so long this was about as lovely as I could have
hoped for for finally paying off this experience
and uh and yeah like I cannot wait to watch this
again like this is it's yeah the full peak of
zany you know sort of overwhelming Jim car and you
can see certainly variations of the kind of movie
that would become a Jim Carrey movie in light of
something like this um but yeah man this was just
such a blast and I thought it was really well you
know attuned to what it was trying to be it had
just the right amount of tempered dimensionality
uh to you know sell all the things it was trying
to sell I don't really know much of of I feel
like this director's named Chuck Russell is
kind of familiar um but yeah yeah just the idea
of a Looney Tune hero or not even hero it's not
even superh hero that's the thing it's like you
could be but it's yeah it's all about how you use
it ah this guy directed the Scorpio and King and
Nightmare on Elm Street 3 okay Dream Warriors one
of the best ones not bad at all okay um so yeah
man I was really enthralled by this this was super
fun and uh and yeah I mean I don't really know
what else you could say about it uh just firing
on all cylinders lots of craftsmanship and good
you know visual work on display and uh yeah a real
marriage of every facet of film making and movie
Magic coming together so hey guys leave me your
thoughts and uh yeah what else should I check
out what are the Jim Carrey movies I've seen
a handful of his Classics but there's certainly
ones I haven't seen and certainly ones where you
know I would have probably been so young that if
I had been in the room for them I don't remember
them now so yeah I'm excited like again Dumb
and Dumber and now this have me very excited
to check out more Jim Carrey uh you know Classics
moving on cuz uh cuz yeah and especially in the
day and age of the comic book movie this holds
up like really well for the most part and it's
not even there aren't a ton of things it's like
even within its own internal logic and it's not
a movie that requires you to be too anal specific
about the internal logic you're like the rules are
fun and fanciful and you can ask questions about
them but there's enough of everything and enough
thought of everything to I don't know just yeah
sell them very nicely and in a time where you
know again we are so saturated with this kind
of thing albeit not in this tone at all uh and
and as comic book movies try to figure out how to
reincorporate humor without making themselves a
joke I feel like there's such a stigma from the
time in which people just didn't take anything
comic book seriously before you proved through a
Batman or something that they could be serious uh
yeah I I feel like now we're in this weird place
with comic book humor where you know you could
stand to learn a thing or two from a movie like
this not that everything has to be slapstick but
anyway yeah I I really appreciated this and I hope
you did too uh so hey leave me your thoughts and
I'll catch you on the next one much love and hey
before we go let's do a patron of the day shout
out Eric Horseman what's up buddy listen uh I
just wanted to say if there's anybody it's a
classic John shout out cuz if there's anybody at
patreon I would be thrilled to see Dawn the mask
and who they turn into under those you know
circumstances and pretenses it's you buddy I
mean the amount I feel like you would be like
the PE sort of like uh Tasmanian Devil pepy
law kind of presence very very I don't know
if you would be a bugs or a Daffy see that's
the thing there's so many possibilities and uh
yeah and you're a colorful guy you've got the
rejects to two which would probably like come
to life the real would Spin and it would like
pop out in 3D and there would be flames you
could use it to light a cigar cigar at and
then it would explode uh you know all the
possibilities and then you could you know
tornado your way out here sweep us up take us
back to Atlanta and you can show us around and
uh I just think that that would be a lovely
and wonderful experience so hey work on that
get yourself a voodoo mask and uh I'll catch
you on the next one but seriously here at the
start of the year you know seeing your name
in in our you know Master list here just the
amount of love you have shown us the amount of
time you've dedicated to just you know being on
this ship with us and being supportive and being
lovely really really appreciate you and uh yeah
much love for now and we'll catch you next time
Eric and everyone else all right that's the video
[Music] cheers